klasse dass das überzeugt mich immer
wieder hallo mein name ist luca
letztlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge turbo diesmal hatte ich spiele das
ganze spiel mal wieder was bei euch zwar
nicht so gut ankommt aber ich mag das
spiel halt total und darum geht es auch
in einem kanal ist das worauf er bock
habt ihr feiert nicht von daher habe ich
auch keinen erfolg so bodis man spielen
wir wie immer mit dieser person hier die
schon triumphal auf dem skateboard
triumphiert ich habe mir diesmal die
strecke space programm ausgesucht die
ist sehr groß ich klicke jetzt einfach
mal auf start mit dem skateboard und ich
schau mal wo das hinführt wels ecken
slater
respekt man das war heftig gut gerade
ich habe mich jetzt mal für ein anderes
gefährt entschieden und zwar dieses hier
das ist optimist prime rindermist
optimus prime los optimismus bleibt
optimist du kannst es schaffen ich glaub
total an day respekt man das war stark
vor allem fährt er auf dieser rampe zu
schmeiß weg runter fährt über ihn drüber
rollt wieder zurück und fährt noch mal
über luca darüber wie krank ist er bitte
ich habe jetzt mal einfach diese
schnelle auto hier genommen mal zu
schauen ob es mit einem schnellen auto
irgendwo mein gott er fährt er ganz
schön schnell an der kleine luca
autoclubs gerade wieder die seite runter
und ist tatsächlich auch gerade total
zerstört worden
am neuen highscore ab jetzt wissen wir
dass luca das auto verlassen hat und
jetzt wird sie nicht interessieren wo
luca da hinten ist einfach mein arm luca
dann hinten seinen arm verloren und ist
auch voll in den asphalt hier
eingekracht alter weise um
da hinten ist mein auto angekommen
es gab in diesem video schon so viele
momente wo ich mich bei luca einfach
gedacht hat er hat sich wahrscheinlich
gerade alle knochen gebrochen da ist man
skateboard nicht geklappt da habe ich
mir gedacht ich nehme einfach mal ein
dreirad fahrrad was tust du da was macht
das dreifach kritik genau ab jetzt ist
dreh total durch fährt dann einfach die
rampe wieder hoch das war's ganze
strecke als natürlich space program das
heißt man muss irgendwie nach oben
kommen deswegen werde ich jetzt mystery
kinder die hören will und wir haben hier
natürlich auch noch den space weiter
aber die jugendlichen space sollte oder
auch nicht
das war ein super crash da es mit keinem
schnellen auto geklappt hat nehme ich
jetzt den formel 1 wagen
klasse dass das überzeugt mich immer
wieder was wollt ihr mich verarschen mit
vollspeed brettert er da hoch fliegt in
alle einzelteile und luca hat da gerade
ein kanu formel-1-wagen bewahre einfach
dieses strecke gehen mit fullspeed hoch
und
boss luca hier verlieren wir luca der
formel 1 wagen fährt weiter hoch und
luca luca hat sich da wieder so ein
halbes kilo gebaut und schlittert mit
dem kanu ganz locker fällt hier runter
und klatscht jetzt auch dann und auch
nochmal da auf den und jetzt ist er
komplett tod wahrscheinlich dass früher
alles nicht so sicher geklappt hat habe
ich luke einfach mal eine andere pose
empfohlen uns diese hiermit der wird er
auf jeden fall weniger schaden davon
tragen ihr geld auch mal okay das ist
komplett nach hinten losgegangen baum
luca dies meistens hier sicherer das
schaffst du die
respekt dass also das ist auch stark
jetzt bist du hier die diva hinten auf
den
ich könnte ich die ganze zeit nur spaß
haben diesen komischen formel-1-wagen
alter das macht am meisten spaß in
dieser ganzen strecke ich kann hier alle
möglichen posten
sollte andy was ich dazu sagen soll
jetzt siehts auf jeden fall schon mal
viel besser aus
an der stelle beende ich dieses video